LEONARD LAW: Hi, guys.
I'm Leonard Law.
I'm one of the product
managers at Google
that helps take care of
our Enterprise Strategy.
Now, the reason I love
working with Google Cloud
is seeing companies that are
driving innovation and business
transformation in their firms.
But I have to be honest.
When I think of
agriculture and clouds,
I usually think about
rain, not technology.
But that's why sometimes
innovation comes
from surprising
places, and that's
why it's my incredible pleasure
today to introduce you to Teddy
Bekele from Land O'Lakes
TEDDY BEKELE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much, and thank
you for coming to the session.
I really appreciate it.
I'm really excited to tell our
story and some of the things
we've done here.
I lead IT for one of the
divisions within Land O'Lakes.
I'll talk a little
bit about that.
And then Joey Jablonski from
Cloud Technology Partners
is here to tell us
about the journey that
helped us along the way.
So with that, what are we
going to talk about today?
And I'm actually going
to read this, because I
don't want to screw it up.
I tried to memorize it, and
I was kind of forgetting,
So by 2050, the world's
exploding demand
will require farms to feed
upwards of 10 billion people.
Global leader in precision
agriculutre, Land O'Lakes,
uses a novel application
of cloud-scale compute
and analytics to
revolutionize modern farming
to produce more
corn on fewer acres
today compared to 50 years ago.
What does that mean?
That means that I get
to do things like,
when I was a kid, what you
want to do when you grow up?
I want to solve world hunger.
And some of the things I'm able
to do now is actually do that,
and I get to do that
using cloud, which
is really, really exciting.
So, first of all, who here
has heard of Land O'Lakes?
Awesome-- most hands.
If you haven't, see me later.
I have packets of
butter for you.
We'll hand those out, right?
So I gave you one clue-- butter.
What else do we make?
Anybody have any ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TEDDY BEKELE: What was that?
AUDIENCE: Cat food.
TEDDY BEKELE: Cat food,
oh yeah-- so Purina.
So one of the names under
Land O'Lakes is a Purina.
And so we made animal feed, and
actually, not quite cat food,
because cat and dog is owned by
Nestle, but every other animal.
So think of farm animals--
cattle, chickens, horses
and all that.
We have feed for that.
And then the largest
division within Land O'Lakes
that most people
don't know about
is actually our crop inputs
business under the name
Winfield, and that's what we'll
talk a little bit about today
is what Winfield is,
and who we are, and then
how we've taken technology
to the next level.
And really what we do as a
crop input distributors is
we buy seed, crop protection,
plant nutrition products
from big manufacturers
and then sell them
to our customers, who
are actually our owners.
And those customers, in
turn, sell them to growers.
So we work closely
on the ag fields
with a lot of agronomists
and with a lot of farmers,
trying to help them
solve different problems.
Now, one of the
big things for us
is because you kind of talk
about, OK, so you have butter.
You have crop inputs.
You have animal feed.
How does that all-- it's kind
of a weird holding company.
And actually, it's not.
It's actually
carefully put together
because our owners are, again,
like dairy producers and ag
providers.
And really one of things
that gives us the ability
is to look at the
whole food chain.
So I'm going to
give you an example.
We sell seed, and we also
manufacture some seed.
So you think about we put
that stuff in the ground.
It grows.
And let's say, for
example, that's corn silage
or alfalfa, which are crops.
Those are then fed to animals,
take the example cows.
So we feed the cows,
control the formulation.
And then from those
cows, milk is produced.
We buy that milk back
from the dairy producers.
We make butter, cheese,
milk, et cetera.
And that gets up in the grocery
stores that you guys consume.
So one of the
things we get to see
is the end-to-end-- from
the time something was first
created all the way
down to you guys
consuming it in the stores.
And that becomes a
lot of fun because you
get to see all the
opportunities, risks,
and challenges within
the value chain.
So what are some of
those challenges, right?
So one of the things
we see clearly
is that by 2050, the
world population,
which is at 7 billion now, is
going to go to 9.2 billion.
And actually, the latest numbers
would say that we're actually
going to go up 10.4 billion.
So that's interesting.
So we've got to feed people.
Now, the other thing
is also, in lot
of the developing
countries they're
getting better and better.
So the middle class is rising.
And because the middle
class is rising,
their diets change, and
so they want more protein
in their diet, et cetera.
So what, really, that leads
to is that 70% more food
production than
what we have today
So, OK, you go, that's kind of
interesting-- good statistic
at a high level.
But here's the other side,
which is the challenge.
Only 12% of the land between
now and 2050 is arable.
Actually, no,
that's not correct.
It's 5%.
12% is arable period, 5% because
you have large investments.
You have areas that
don't have water.
You have to put big
irrigation systems
in place, a lot of
infrastructure investments
that don't make sense yet.
So you can only kind
of farm where you can,
and so that is only 5%.
And, by the way,
agriculture is also
one of the most water-intensive
industries out there,
and we require more water
than anything else out there.
It's one of the
oldest industries,
and water is key to that.
So we need 40% more water
than we actually have today.
So that becomes a challenge.
So, really, what do we get
to at the end of the day?
We need to produce
more food, but we
have less resources to do it.
So now in IT, that's not
an uncommon or unheard
of challenge-- do
more with less.
But in agriculture, where
you get to plant a crop once,
you wait a whole
year, and it grows
again, the idea is, OK, what
do you want me to do there?
How does that happen?
How can we make that happen?
Now, the good news is
this is where IT kicks in.
This is where technology
really makes a difference.
So what you see on this chart
is sort of the evolution
of agriculture over time.
So on the x-axis,
you have the years
from the 1800s all the way
till 2050 or 2060 mark.
And there's been some
revolutions along the way.
So the mechanization was
the first revolution.
That's sort of the tractors.
The tractors got smarter, right?
They started to do
more and more things.
And actually, today some of
these tractors and combines
drive themselves.
So the guy actually
sitting in the cab
is watching Netflix, if
he's not on top of his game.
If he's on top of his game,
he's watching crop prices
and making business decisions.
But it's very much automated.
Then you had the
biotech revolution.
That started about the 1950s.
And so, all of a sudden, the
seeds you put in the ground
started, the technology
went into it,
and you could produce
more with what you had.
And that's still what's
fueling agriculture today.
However, this next
revolution is really
going to come from technology,
and what do I mean by that?
So you take the largest
crop in the United States
today, which is corn.
And we produce about, on
average, 170 bushels per acre.
I know for those of
you not in ag, that
doesn't make a lot of sense.
And I was told not to go
into agronomy too much,
but I have to a little
bit for you to get it.
So 170 bushels an acre--
just think of it as a number.
If we were to
increase production
from 170 bushels an acre
to 180 bushels an acre,
that's a 10-bushel increase.
That's the same as creating five
million virtual acres, right?
So essentially, here's the idea,
that, hey, we can [? reduce ?]
production just a little bit.
You can actually produce more
with what you already have.
And, by the way, if you
control those imports,
you can actually keep
the inputs the same
and still produce more.
Now, here's another interesting
statistic for you guys.
The highest recorded yield
for corn in the United States
actually happened last year,
at 530 bushels an acre.
So in a field, not
in a greenhouse
or a lab controlled--
actually, that potential
goes up to 1,000.
But in a given field,
somebody is actually
able to achieve 530
bushels an acre.
So really, if you go
from the average of 170,
and the high end is
530, you're like, well,
how does that happen, right?
Well, if you can make--
agriculture today
is still intuition-driven.
I do it the way my dad did it.
Maybe I disagreed
over a few things.
I'm going to make those changes.
But, essentially,
it's more of a feel.
It's still an art.
But you start bringing
in data-driven facts
to these farmers that say,
hey, use this technology
and use some crop modeling.
Use some scouting.
Use some drone imagery,
for that matter.
You can kind of see what's
happening in your large fields,
so I'm not talking
about a small field,
but like a 100-acre field.
And then, because you can
make better decisions,
now you can achieve this
high range you can get to.
I'll give you just an example.
This is one of the
tools we use today.
And what you see here
is-- so what we do
is we take satellite imagery.
So we take an image, and it's
got to be clear, with no clouds
in the way.
But if we're able to
achieve that, then
the reflection off the light
off a plant, it's different.
From a healthy plant,
it reflects differently
than an unhealthy plant.
What we do is we take a lot
of the light reflection.
We assign it a score, let's
say a 10, if it's good,
and two, if it's bad.
And then you take a color,
like dark green for the good,
and red for the two.
And essentially,
now you can create
like a geospatial algorithm
with a file on top of it
that shows you how that
field is performing.
And nobody's ever stepped
foot on the field.
So what you can see here
is in zone number one,
that's a hard area.
You can see there
that we hardly have
anything growing in that spot.
Makes sense, right?
That probably was
a score of zero.
And then in number two,
which was the dark green,
you can barely see
that Winfield sign
in there, which means that
crop's doing really well.
So now, all of a
sudden, you sort of
have this idea of, like,
OK, I can understand where
the crop is
struggling, and maybe I
need to do something there,
or the crop is doing well.
So that's one decision
you can make off of this.
Another decision could be,
hey next year, when I plant,
I know that area number
two and number three really
are high-yielding.
So what I want to
do there is maybe
I'll push the
population, which means
I'll put more seeds into the
ground in those specific spots.
And if I do that,
I can yield more
than I do if I put the same
amount in zone number one.
It's called a
variable-rate planting.
So, all of a sudden,
with the same amount
of inputs that you
had before, you're
actually able to produce more.
So this is the
type of technology
we're getting into today-- a lot
of fun, very, very exciting--
but again, going to go
from this intuition art
down into a bit of a science,
which is pretty exciting.
And another thing here
to note, for example,
is we talk a lot about is
agriculture using technology?
And I was talking to one of
our presidents in our division.
I was trying to explain to
him what IOT was, right?
He's like, IOT, what is that?
Internet of Things.
He's like, you kind of just
said the same thing again.
I'm not really sure
what that means.
So I'm like, OK, so you
have these sensors that you
can put in devices or
machines that really
weren't doing anything before.
They were dumb devices.
Now you're putting something
in there that starts talking.
And all of a sudden,
this device has a voice.
It's sort of telling
you what it's doing.
You collect this with a
whole bunch of other devices.
You run some analytics
on top of that.
And, by the way, now you
have some great insights.
He's like, oh, wow.
We do that in agriculture
with the new stuff
we're doing, right?
Each plant is a thing,
like an internet of things.
So if you think about it, in
agriculture, we didn't even
think about it before,
but we're actually
doing these type of things,
where internet of things
is not necessarily a
sensor in something.
It could just be the thing
itself is actually telling you,
hey, I'm happy and
healthy, or I'm sick,
and I'm not doing well-- so
kind of interesting stuff.
So how does cloud
fit into all this?
Well, here's the decision.
So all these great tools
are coming to the market.
We have one.
Our competitors have some.
A lot of partners in
the market are really
helping us put a lot
of cool tools together.
But what's happening?
These tools don't
talk to each other.
A lot of these are
geospatial files.
They're very big.
They're very complex.
You have prescriptions.
You have tissue samples.
You have scouting reports.
And the idea is for one
tool to be really effective,
it needs information
from another tool.
And, yes, we could create a
connection between the two,
but some of this information
is actually common to many
of these tools.
And what we want to
do is tell the farmer,
here, go use these three things
when your crop is growing.
Then you'll get from
that 170 bushels to 200.
But he's, like,
well, using three is
going to be really complicated.
I have a barrier to
use it to begin with.
Then I have to re-enter
stuff three times?
That doesn't work.
So that's where we
came to the idea,
is we need some sort of
centralized cloud solution.
We need something that's
going to collect information
from different tools, right?
So you see the R7 tool
up there on the left.
And we're going to put some
boundaries and prescriptions
from there into this
centralized place.
And from the
centralized place, we're
going to then give that
information to another tool.
So this was the concept that
we came up with, and said,
this is a really neat idea.
And, by the way, it
should live in the cloud.
It makes sense, because
these files get humongous,
and we have 300,000 farmers
in the United States,
so this is going to
get bigger and bigger.
And so that's where the
idea of like, maybe we
need to look at
this, and maybe we
need to look at a cloud
solution concept came into play.
And so we reached out, and we
looked at the various cloud
solutions available out there.
And one of the things we
found that GCP really offered
was like, really,
kind of fit our needs.
For the things we were looking
for, with the geospatial needs,
with some of the
newer technologies
that we were embarking on, this
seemed to be a really good fit.
And Google also turned us
to one of their partners
that could help us in the space,
and this where Cloud Technology
Partners came in.
And they really
helped us figure out
how we put this infrastructure
in place so that we could
really enable our tools and
enable the farmers to make
a better decision.
So I'll turn it to Joey here,
and he'll kind of talk you
through the-- they told me to
keep the agronomy to a minimum,
so hopefully I did that.
But he's going to go more into
the technical infrastructure
and how we built the solution.
JOEY JABLONSKI:
Great, thanks, Teddy.
[APPLAUSE]
So, as Teddy mentioned, I work
for Cloud Technology Partners.
We got the privilege of spending
almost an entire year working
very closely with the
team at Land O'Lakes
as part of the Winfield
group, building out Data Silo.
When we first started with Data
Silo, we had a million ideas.
We sat down with the
agronomists across Land O'Lakes.
We sat down with agronomists
from their partner retailers.
And what we knew was that
we had a million features
that we wanted to build.
We knew that we had
a problem we wanted
to solve around integrating
data from a variety
of different sources.
And we knew that we wanted to
use the latest and greatest
in modern technologies.
So we started with an
assessment of the cloud
vendors that are out there.
We settled on the
Google platform
as the capability that gave
us the fastest time-to-market.
So we were able to
iterate very, very quickly
on what we were developing.
We were able to try new
technologies without having
to build servers, without having
to put them in the data center.
Because of Google's
portfolio, we
were able to try different
things-- BigQuery, Cloud
SQL, Data Store-- and use the
technologies that made the best
sense for us, from a
development perspective,
from a feature
perspective, and also
from a geospatial perspective.
Everything we did in Data
Silo was spatial in nature.
So being able to leverage
Google Maps, being
able to leverage some of the
expertise that Google brought,
really gave us an
advantage that allowed
us to get this application
developed and tested quickly.
So what is Data Silo?
At the end of the
day, Data Silos's
going to give us four
sets of capabilities--
the ability to store information
from disparate sources;
the ability to share
that information, to be
able to allow farmers to
give access to their data
to other people; to be able
to search this information,
be able to look at
data by growing season,
by location, by address,
by spatial point;
and most importantly, be
able to control this data,
being able to control
who has access to it,
what systems the data
is fed to automatically.
When we first started
Data Silo, our focal point
was very much
internal systems there
at Land O'Lakes and systems that
the farmers leverage-- tools
like R7 for building
crop prescriptions,
essentially defining
how many seeds I'm
going to plant per given acre;
tools like Scout Pro, that
give us the ability
to scout a field
and take images and samples; and
then tools like NutriSolutions,
that are laboratory management
capabilities that show us test
results and sample information.
Data Silo was initially built
to bring these together,
but most importantly to connect
to the rest of the ecosystem
that's being built within the
agriculture space-- companies
like Monsanto, companies
like John Deere that are also
putting data online.
Prior to tools like
Data Silo, prior
to some of these
integrations that we built,
literally, the method for moving
data around in the agriculture
space is USB drives.
It was not uncommon
for someone to download
a file on their computer
onto a USB drive,
give it to a retailer,
who then plugs it
into a monitor on their
tractor to go use that data,
and then do the
reverse-- download
the as-planted information
from the monitor,
put it back onto
the USB drive, snail
mail it back to somebody else.
Data Silo's meant to
solve the problems,
so we're not moving
USB drives anymore.
One of the key elements, though,
with Data Silo that we wanted
to focus on from
early on is access
to information and privacy.
So there's certain
information that farmers
are extremely sensitive to
keeping confidential and not
sharing with a wider audience.
Yield information is that.
Growers don't want to share how
successful their fields are.
They have their own
patterns and practices
that they use to get
that level of efficiency.
They don't want to share
that information very widely.
There's also, like any industry,
legal rules-- information
about plots of land,
GIS coordinates
that make them up, or
protected information that
need to be defended properly.
So when we built Data Silo,
we built it from the ground up
with an access control
infrastructure that
allows us to ensure that the
owner of that data, the grower
or the operator of that field,
can control exactly who sees
their data, when they
can audit that access,
and, most importantly,
they can revoke that access
and control it.
So I want to talk a little
bit about the development
timeline of Data Silo.
We learned a lot as we
went into this process.
And we went into it
with one key assumption,
was that we don't know
what we're doing here.
This is the first of its kind
application in the market.
So let's not try to invent
things that are too far along,
without getting
market validation,
without getting experts to
validate what we're doing.
So we started this project.
I actually remember the
kickoff for this project
was on my birthday of last year.
So I will remember
that day well.
I got to spend it
with a new client.
So we started the project with a
variety of discovery workshops.
So we sat down with
about 20 people
from across Land O'Lakes, from
across partners and retailers
of theirs.
And we just did brainstorming
sessions-- writing out
every possible idea about
features, usability, drawing
out potential UIs on the board.
We then moved into
designing our data model.
So one of the challenges
that we ran into early
was that we're integrating
data from a variety
of different systems.
Some of them are file-based.
Some of them are
relational database-based.
But most importantly,
no single person
had ever done design
across all of them,
so there was no clean mapping
of data between those systems.
So we started with
building a data model that
would allow us to ingest
data from source systems
and put it into a standard data
model that would then allow us
to evolve over time and
build standardized APIs,
standardized workflows.
And then we built a Data Silo.
One for one of our real powerful
proof points on Data Silo
was one of the key
features that we
wanted to demonstrate
to the agronomists was
visual display of field
boundaries-- so, essentially,
lines that designate where a
field is in a certain area.
From a development perspective,
not an extremely complicated
thing to do.
There's libraries
out there that do it.
Google Maps provides
functionality.
But being able to do this
with live data that came out
of other Land O'Lakes systems
was a very important step
because of the file
format challenges.
That first feature
that we built,
we were able to demonstrate at
the end of the second week--
so essentially our first
sprint as part of the project.
This really shows
the power of being
able to empower our developers.
We weren't focused
on deploying servers.
We weren't focused on
networking problems.
We were focused on writing code,
deploying it in App Engine,
and then testing it.
But most importantly, not
testing it from a developer
perspective only, but letting
our agronomists, the end
consumers of this
application, test it as well.
We did a security assessment
early on in the project.
We brought in the security
team from Land O'Lakes.
We brought in an
expert from my team
to really make sure that
the model that we built
was defendable, and
that the data was going
to be protected in a
way our growers would
be comfortable with it.
And then, finally--
showing these boundaries
that I talked about.
The key here is that we've
learned a very important lesson
around April of this project and
made a very fundamental shift.
We started this project with
a very file-based mindset.
How can we share files?
How can we control
access to files?
The reason we did
that is because we
were coming from the
agronomist perspective.
The way they interacted was
they moved files around.
They put them on a USB drive.
They emailed them to people.
From a development perspective,
this became very difficult.
When you get data in
various file formats,
the quality is poor, people
muck with the extensions because
of their virus protection.
Files are hard to
parse, particularly
when they're shape
files because there
are a variety of different
standards in the industry that
are used.
So this file-centric
approach causes
a lot of problems in
the development cycle.
We were running into
data quality issues,
running into
performance problems.
So we sit we stepped back
a little bit and said,
OK, let's stop looking at
it from a file perspective.
Do growers really need
files and what they do?
And it occurred to
us that they don't.
At the end of the
day, the growers
need to control information
about their fields.
They need to control
prescriptions,
as-planted information,
GIS information.
So we threw out all of
that file-based approach
that we took with
the application
and really switched
to a completely GIS
or a spatial-based application.
This was actually
really good, this
allowed us to simplify
our data model.
Literally, about 1/2 of our
tables and relationships
in our data model
completely went away
as we went to the
spatial approach.
Because we no longer had
to build relationships
in the database, we were
able to infer them spatially.
Simplified our database-- we
did move database platforms
as part of this change.
We went to a database that
supported a lot more GIS
capability than the initial
one we started with.
And then, finally,
building a lot
more UI capabilities-- one
of the other challenges
we had learned as we started
to do iterative demos
after every sprint was that we
were getting a lot of feedback,
particularly from Teddy
and some of his peers,
that the rendering on
the screen wasn't proper,
that elements weren't
showing up on the screen.
And it finally
occurred to us that we
were doing all of our
development on a desktop.
We were assuming
the retailers were
going to be using a
desktop interface as well.
And it turns out people like
Teddy don't even own desktops.
They do everything
from their phone.
So we made a very drastic
change in the development cycle
here and moved to a completely
mobile-first development cycle,
with the desktop interfaces
coming as a secondary testing
and secondary development.
This enrichment of the
UI, a lot of the retailers
gave us very positive feedback.
Because anyone in
the field is first
going to be on a tablet or
a phone, and much later on
they'll be on a full
desktop or a laptop.
This second phase
of the project,
mid-April, we started building
a lot of our APIs as well.
So instead of moving
files between systems,
we got to a very
programmatic approach.
We were able to allow API
connectivity into Data Silo.
This became a very
important focal point.
Because suddenly, systems
like R7, NutriSolutions
could connect automatically,
send a lot of data
to Data Silo, and
external systems
could query that information
and get it as well.
We did another
security assessment.
We made a lot of
fundamental changes
to the architecture
in this second phase.
So we did a secondary
security assessment.
And, ultimately,
what we ended up
with was a very spatial
application that people could
find locations on the map and
find all the data associated
with it.
They could query by season.
They could query by type of crop
and find information that way,
rather than this file-based
approach with the naming
conventions that
become inconsistent.
This got us a lot of
very positive feedback,
particularly from the retailers
that we were demoing and using
as our live audience.
We also re-platformed the app.
We had actually started
with Google Compute
Engine when we first started
building the app for speed.
As we moved a lot more of
these spatial capabilities,
we actually made a choice to
move to Google Computer instead
of App Engine, mainly to give
us a lot more GIS functionality,
simplify things
for the developers.
So this file-centric
to spatial-centric
was really-- it was
a big light bulb.
I remember the day in
the conference room
with [? Anonth, ?]
one of the architects
that works for Teddy,
where we finally
realized that this was
the solution to all
of our feedback we were getting
about a poor UI experience,
about poor performance.
This file-based approach
was the challenge.
So let's talk a little bit about
the functional architecture.
So when we built out
Data Silo, we really
built three
functional areas that
are unique in terms
of what they provide.
We built a presentation layer.
And this presentation
layer gives us
things like search capabilities,
the login, all of our landing
pages, but also more advanced
features like Impersonation.
Impersonation was critical
from a support perspective.
Imagine, you're a farmer.
You're working out in
Indiana, and you've
got a problem with Data Silo.
It's not showing
the data you expect.
You call the Land
O'Lakes support line.
That individual should be able
to impersonate that grower
and identify exactly
what they're seeing.
So we built those
sorts of capabilities
that came from feedback
from the retailer community.
We also built our access layer,
so the APIs that we built,
built our data transformations.
But most importantly,
we focused on compliance
with industry standards.
So [? OWADA ?] is an
agriculture standards body
that's focusing
on data exchange,
trying to drive some standards
for how these organizations
work together.
And then, finally, we built
our data layer, so our database
plus our associated
functionality
around how we store things
like tissue samples,
like prescriptions.
So from a logical
architecture, the application
was built to be highly
scalable, but within reason.
So, Teddy mentioned earlier that
there's about 300,000 farmers
here in the United States.
That's good, actually.
So we never had to
build an application
for a million users.
We're never going to have a
million simultaneous users
on Data Silo.
So we built things
with technologies that
were proven around that idea.
So some of the technologies
that we built Data Silo,
people will look at it and
say, well, we were using those
five years ago.
And it's true; we
were, and they work.
So we didn't want
to over complicate
the issue for a
couple of reasons.
One, finding software engineers
for extremely modern languages
is much more difficult than
for proven languages, like PHP,
like Java.
So we went with technologies
that were proven.
We also went with
a database model
that provide us
highly scalability,
because the reality
is it's a very
read-intensive environment.
We're really not
writing that much data
in the grand scheme of things.
So we used a more
traditional database model
with read-only slaves
to give us scalability.
So I mentioned earlier
about our data model.
And one of the areas
we were able to hugely
simplify Data Silo was when we
moved to a geospatial approach
rather than a file approach.
What this allowed
us to do was instead
of building relationships
in a database between things
like fertilizer prescriptions
and a field, a field in a farm,
a farm and a grower, we were
able to infer that information.
Because a seed prescription
or a fertilizer
prescription have
a spatial location.
Our field has a boundary.
So identify whether that point
fits in the boundary becomes
a mathematical calculation
rather than hard relationships
in the database.
This also became important.
Some of the early feedback
we got from retailers
was, well, I want to
upload a crop prescription.
But I haven't
defined my field yet.
I haven't built
in the Data Silo.
So by the spatial
nature, we're essentially
able to go take all of our
data, throw it into Data Silo,
and then identify how it's
related to one another.
And then as time goes on, you
can add additional fields.
You can add additional
views on it.
One of the key things to keep
in mind in the agriculture space
is that a field is not
a life-long concept.
A field tends to
be something that's
memorable to the grower-- you
know, Joe's field, Bob's farm.
Sometimes there's an address
associated with it, maybe
what road it's on, the
intersection of what highways.
But most importantly,
that field-- the polygon,
the spatial information for it
changes every single growing
season, because you may
have taken out a tree that
was in the corner of the field.
The stream may be running
a little bit higher
flow this year than
it was last year.
So that information
is constantly
changing year after year.
So as we built
our data model, we
tried to stay away from any
assumptions about relationships
for fields for the data
associated with it,
and let the grower
choose those--
let them decide how the data
is related to one another.
So this is another
representation
of the data model.
So at the center,
what you'll see
is that we define resources.
And in Data Silo, what we
defined was essentially
anything as a resource--
a prescription, a field,
a boundary, tissue
samples, and soil samples.
Those resources then
have access controls
that associate with them.
So we have tables that define
who can access the data, what
they can do with it.
Most importantly, we
have an audit table,
so we can identify
who changed data when,
who uploaded data when,
where it came from.
And then, of course, all of
our user information-- user
information is where we
store things like defaults
when user logged in.
We actually had a concept in
the application called widgets,
that when you log
into the application,
there's a widget that tells you
how many acres you have mapped
in the system, how many
crop prescriptions you have,
harvest information, so
those sorts of defaults
as to what experience the
user wants when they log in.
From a functional
perspective, we
had a variety of
technologies that we used.
At the top tier, so
essentially presentation,
we used Bootstrap as our mobile
and our responsive framework,
supported by HTML and
a little bit of PHP.
All of our APIs were
essentially endpoints
that we exposed
and wrote in PHP.
At the application
level, we really
built two functional areas.
We built all of our
business logic in PHP.
It's easy to mock up.
It's fast to develop, easy to
redo if we have to throw out
sections of the code.
But most importantly, we
built our file processing.
So one item I've mentioned
a lot is shape files.
Essentially, a shape
file is a GIS standard
for how you exchange
information about a field
or a bunch of points.
Well, there's a certain
type of shape file
you get in agriculture
called an as-planted.
An as-planted
essentially defines
how many seeds were planted at
what GIS locations in a field.
Well, you imagine a field
that's even a few acres.
These files tend to have
millions and millions
of points.
So we wanted a very highly
scalable processing engine
to bring in these shape
files, to decompose them
into something that we
can store in the database
in a meaningful way.
So we built this
Python file processor
that could bring all
this data and process it.
And, ultimately, we
used the Zend framework
as our PHP framework to
get us going quickly,
build technology quickly.
The other piece that we talked
about quite a bit was API.
I think over the course of the
nine months to build Data Silo,
we probably had about 150 hours
of meetings on API design.
And the struggle we
had for API design
was that there's, first
off, no industry standard.
So there really wasn't
anything we could key off of.
There are several industry
bodies that are there,
things like Adapt,
organizations like [? OWADA. ?]
But they're not ratified yet.
So there are standards that
we could try to leverage
to the best of our ability,
but they're really not
finalized yet.
The other element is
that the API structure
gets very complicated
as you start to look
at all the potential options.
So one of the things that
we did early on in Data Silo
is we really kept a small focus.
We started with
connectivity to R7.
So that meant all we had to
deal with was prescriptions,
and then we started
talking to NutriSolutions.
So then we could bring in
tissue and soil samples.
We took this same
approach with the APIs.
So we built APIs to start with
a small subset of our data types
and then increasing from there.
So from a platform
perspective, we've
used a variety of technologies.
As I mentioned we, did start
with App Engine-- really,
really get going quickly,
built technology.
Ultimately, we moved
to Compute Engine,
just because there were
some GIS capabilities
that we needed that we
needed to install locally
in a full operating system.
And then we leveraged Google's
Cloud Storage quite a bit.
The idea behind
cloud storage was
that all of these files
that were coming inbound,
these shape files, these other
exchange formats like CSVs,
we needed a place to store
them in their raw format.
We weren't actually
decomposing all the files
in their entirety in Data Silo.
We only extracted
the information
we needed to provide the
user with the experience
that we were targeting
for Data Silo.
So we stored all
of our raw data--
any JSON objects that came
in as part API connectivity,
we stored in Cloud
Storage as well.
So if we ever needed to
go back and recreate data,
restructure the database,
we had the raw information
to go do that as we needed.
The other power of the platform
that we see longer term
is as we add
additional data types.
One of the visions for
Data Silo long term
is to start bringing
in satellite imagery
so that people can enhance that
with the information stored
in Data Silo.
So tools like Cloud Storage
will become very valuable.
As we start to bring in more
and more tissue sample, soil
samples, as more sensors get
used, tools like BigQuery
will become very powerful
to be able to connect
to very quickly and query
large amounts of information
that is heavily read-only.
So I'll talk a little bit
about our lessons learned.
The cloud was good, and
there were parts of it
that were bad as well.
So it was good from a
flexibility perspective.
We were able to build
apps very, very quickly.
The struggle was there is
a learning curve for it.
You need to be cognisant upfront
that the way you do operations,
the way you build
your environment,
the way you monitor
it is different.
So as part of the
project, what we did
is we sat down with
some of Teddy's peers
that run the IT operations
side and spent time
talking with them
about how they would
operate a system like this.
We didn't go into
it blind, saying,
we build the application,
and then it's perfect.
We realized that we build it.
Then we hand it off
to an operations team.
Then they have to run with it
for the foreseeable future.
So we sat down with
those operations teams
early and made sure they had
the instrumentation they needed.
One of the pieces
that their operations
team was very sensitive
to was availability
of the application.
So we actually instrumented the
application, [? for ?] a lot
of monitoring capabilities.
So their monitoring
systems could
connect to the application
in different ways
and verify that the file
processor was working
independently from the UI,
which was working independently
from the business
logic on the back end.
So we instrumented it for
those operations folks.
The other piece is
understanding your user base.
There's really two factors here.
First is the scale comment
that I made earlier.
If you're not ever going
to have a million users,
don't design for
a million users.
You're just adding
unnecessary complexity.
We were lucky in that we
had a population of users
that we knew and we
understood very well.
They are also a group that
we can plan very well.
The thing about a
growing season is
we can plan for it
every single year.
We know when the growing
season is going to start.
We know when people
are going to harvest.
So we can plan our computing
power, what we need,
how many users are going
to come into these systems,
based on that one-year cycle.
And then use technologies that
your team is comfortable with.
One of the biggest struggles
I see in organizations
is shoehorning in technology
is that the development teams,
the operations teams
aren't comfortable with.
You're asking for an
organization that's
first going to push back,
but, secondarily, not
going to be as effective because
they don't have the technology
depth.
One of the reasons we chose
the technologies we did
is because there are
people at the Land O'Lakes
organization within
their development team
that understand
them and can take
that long-term cycle of
adding additional features,
debugging problems.
So pick technologies that your
company, your organization
is comfortable with.
It lowers that barrier
to entry, makes
people more comfortable
with cloud as a platform,
because they're not having
to learn as many new things
at the same time.
But once you're on
the cloud, then it
gives you a lot more technology
that you can take advantage
of once you're comfortable.
Teddy, pass it back to
you for the last slide?
TEDDY BEKELE: Yeah, absolutely.
So you kind of walked
through a little bit of how
we solved this problem, right?
And one of the things, as Joey
was talking, what's interesting
is the name Data Silo, right?
So if you kind listened
to what he said,
it was anything
but a silo, right?
The idea is to make it more of a
hub to move information around.
But one of the
things about adapting
to your customers,
silo makes a lot
of sense in a farmer's world
because your prized possession
is your grain that
comes off your fields.
And that grain's
stored in a silo.
So for them, that was the idea,
that you put it in a silo,
and then that's where the
information's going to be.
Now what you see
here on the chart
is a little bit of
Land O'Lakes story,
a little bit of stories
kind of ag as a whole,
and what you see is
you have this chart.
And the red line really
represents the planted acres.
And so over the years, it's
kind of gone down a little bit,
depending on the years in
which farmers didn't make money
so they planted less, to
years where they made money
so it went up a little bit.
But the idea hasn't
changed over the years.
However, the crop production
has gone up, right?
And so that's with a revolution
on the equipment, revolution
on the biotech.
And really what
we're hoping for is
now is that the
technology is going
to be the next frontier--
really the software development,
cloud, IOT, all the things we
talk about at this conference
are really what's
going to take us
to the next level of
producing more with less.
And so that's the story we have,
and we want to continue it.
Really happy with kind of
the place where we are today,
and I engage all of you to
get familiar with agriculture
and some of the things we're
doing in technology there.
Like I said, the
opportunity is great, right?
We talk about that
170-bushel-an-acre average all
the way up.
There's the potential
to get to 550.
Really, what's going
to get us there
is the adoption of
new technologies
of kind of changing
farming from intuition
to a data-driven industry.
So with that, I thank you
for your participation,
and I will take any
questions at this point.
One question there.
JOEY JABLONSKI:
Oh so the question
was, were there are cloud
providers that we looked
at as part of this process?
Yeah, so we did look
across the industry
when we first kicked
off this project.
We had a small set
of requirements
that we used for that
vendor assessment.
First and foremost was speed.
We wanted our
development team to focus
on building an application
that we could demo.
We wanted a provider
that was scalable.
We wanted one that
we knew was going
to be there for the long run.
We also wanted a provider
that was flexible,
that had a diverse enough
portfolio of technologies
that if we made the wrong
technology decision early,
we could pivot very
quickly without having
to change providers.
So we did look across the
board of the other public cloud
providers, did a pretty
detailed assessment,
and ultimately settled on
Google as the path forward.
TEDDY BEKELE: Yeah,
it was interesting.
The only thing I'll add is when
we were doing that assessment
and we had CTP in
with us, the questions
were, OK, so we kind
of get at a high level.
You want to build something
where you can store some files,
maybe data, not really sure.
And then I was like, yep,
that's what we want to do.
Can you tell us more about it?
No, that's about what
we want to do, right?
So the idea was we had
to go through an idea.
It's, OK, let's start building
something that can get us
within six weeks we can have
a proof of concept for you.
We worked together on that.
We learn, and then we
integrate from there.
And that's really
what helped us.
And I would say we went
through four or five iterations
before we got to the
point where we said, yeah,
I think we think we've
got what we need.
JOEY JABLONSKI: Yeah, and
it was an interesting cycle.
We did a traditional
agile development cycle.
We managed a backlog.
We groomed it every
couple of weeks.
We did a sprint demo at
the end of every two weeks.
And the folks in that demo
came from the agronomists
at Land O'Lakes, individuals
from the retailers.
And ultimately what happened is
there were some features that
came out of those demos that the
retailers and the agronomists
like thumbs up, those are great.
Let's keep iterating on those
and make those features better.
There were other features where
the agronomists took one look
at it and said, Yeah,
I know I asked for it,
but I really don't need that.
That feedback was invaluable.
We were able to manage
our time very effectively.
We were able to
focus in on features
that provided real value.
AUDIENCE: For the geographical
information systems,
did you all use completely
Google solutions or something
like Esri or any other solutions
outside the Google [INAUDIBLE]?
JOEY JABLONSKI: And so
for the GIS components,
we actually used PostGIS,
which is an open source
set of libraries that
run on top of Postgres.
So that was our
GIS infrastructure
as part of Data Silo.
Within Land O'Lakes,
there are other systems
that are running
the Esri toolkit,
a lot of the desktop folks.
So a lot of the files
that we were receiving
and the files that we were
producing to send data out
needed to be compliant with
some of the Esri standards
for view perspective,
those types of things.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about how you build the
security solution and some
of the constraints.
But I'm wondering, Teddy,
in terms of like adoption
and earning the
trust of farmers,
putting what I imagine
what is really, really
precious data to them and
other parts of your company,
I'm kind of curious like how
did that work and maybe even
for the application overall?
TEDDY BEKELE: Yeah,
good question.
And data privacy and the whole
trust thing is interesting.
So farmers, if you want to
find a conspiracy theorist,
go to any farm.
And those are the
guys out there.
Everything's coming,
the government out
to get them, all that
good stuff, right?
Now, the one thing I would say
is our system, our company,
the way it's built,
it's a co-op.
So actually, the
growers, the farmers,
own the retail locations, and
the retail locations own us.
So that kind of element
of trust is already there.
So what's interesting
is we would go,
and we, as Winfield
Land O'Lakes,
would try to pitch this
information to a set of growers
to kind of see what
they felt like.
And they're like, I
don't know about putting
my stuff in something like
that, et cetera, et cetera.
But usually when
we went there, we
would go with the
retail, the guy who's
our customer in there.
And he's like, oh, no, you
don't have to worry about that.
That's the type of stuff
I would do for you, right?
You already gave me your USB
drives-- a whole bunch of them
in the office in my desk drawer.
So it's a better way for me
to manage this, so then you
and I can have a conversation
about what we plan next year.
Oh, that's fine.
I mean, that's how that
conversation would go.
So these retail
agronomist that are
kind of local-- I
mean, some of them,
they go to each
other's weddings.
Their kids play
together, et cetera.
So they have that
level of trust.
So it was very important
for us to get those guys
on board, which
is why when we're
doing a lot of the
sprint demos, et cetera,
we had those guys kind
of give us feedback
right away to make sure that
that adoption was there.
And actually, it turns
out this was actually
a need in the industry.
A lot of people--
originally, my intent
was we want to move files around
so we could use these tools.
And that's really
the ultimate goal.
But people just felt
better that if I
have a place where I can
put my data and it's secure,
and it's not like in a USB drive
or my computer that doesn't
turn on anymore
because it has a virus,
this was a lot better solution.
And so that was kind of a
byproduct of it as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I understand the impact
that this kind of Data Silo
could have with the upstream
supply chain and the farmers.
But can you talk
a little bit more
about what you saw as the
business impact with retailers?
TEDDY BEKELE: Yeah,
so for retailers,
the big deal was-- so I would
say as our challenge actually
in adoption was with
the retail community
at first, because it
was like, well, should.
I go with you guys or not?
So we had a natural
hedge there a little bit
because of this
cooperative structure.
So they were willing to
kind of work with us,
and they're already part
of owning Land O'Lakes.
So if their general
manager voted against it,
it would [? certainly ?] be
something we wouldn't do.
But as far as what helped
them at the end of the day
is these guys talk to the
farmers throughout the year.
So they start out
with in the spring,
or let's say in the fall,
they talk about what are we
going to do next year, right?
What are we going to plant?
Which seed do you
want me to order?
How are we going to protect
the field going forward,
because next year
looks like it's
going to be a wet year, et
cetera, et cetera, right?
Then the conversation
moves into the spring,
where actually you plant
the stuff into the field
because the seed arrived.
And then we get into
the crop starts growing.
What kind of decisions
do we make now?
Do we apply more
nitrogen or not?
Which areas?
And all that kind of stuff.
So it's a kind of a mess
today a little bit, right?
So it's almost like you're
running by with the seed--
with everything on fire, right?
Like it's like one thing
and then the other.
So with these tools, they're
able to better manage
that relationship with
the grower, right?
So the idea was OK, so this
tool is going to help you
at this time of the year.
And we're going to tell
you how that works.
This next time,
this is how you're
going to have the conversation.
Then you look at
satellite imagery.
And that's how you can have a
conversation about which area
is struggling.
So with the fact that we
said you could use these four
or five tools now to help
that grower have a discussion,
it's going to enable your
business even further.
Because once they have
a better idea of how
to make these
decisions, and the tools
are connected to
each other, there's
no reason that grower is going
to go somewhere else, right?
So they stick with you, and
that resonated a lot with them.
Because even if they're friends,
at the end of the day, if I got
something else or a better
story from another guy,
I can go over there.
So it showed them
a way to say, this
is how you keep your
strong relationship
even stronger than it is today.
Hopefully, that
answers your question.
LEONARD LAW: With that, I'd like
to just wrap up the session.
Thank you very much,
Teddy, Joey, for your talk.
And thank you all for coming.
JOEY JABLONSKI: Thank you.